yelling
to push for global minimum tax
on corporations let me say that one more
time
yelling to push for global minimum tax
on corporations
cnbc however not just on corporations
she is pitching this to have a tax on
corporations around the world not us by
the way what he has here the story that
you have here kai
is not the story i was looking at is
there the story of she says global tax
or no
it's global on the top of page six okay
janet yellen will call for minimum tax
levy on corporations around the world in
an effort to keep companies from
relocating to find lower rates yellen
will tell
the chicago council on global affairs
conference that established a minimal
global corporate rate will help bring
stability and provide a more level
playing field for all countries
under the biden administration proposals
to raise a corporate tax rate as a way
to pay for 2 trillion dollar
infrastructure improvement plan
the corporate tax rate would climb to 28
percent from a 21
that increase would come just four years
after former president donald trump
slashed it from 35 to 21
which at the time was a heist in the
world at 35. wait back up and say that
again forget about trump
35 to 21. united states corporate tax
dollars years ago in the world
that's right forget about trump what you
feel about them 35 percent those
companies here in america are paying
more tax than anywhere
on the planet companies companies also
had incentivized to hide revenue
offshore something the trump tax cut
also addressed by adding reparation rep
rep
pronounce that word right there uh
repatriation
repatriation in other words big dollars
in savings accounts overseas get
bring it back to us yes the biden plan
would uh call for an increase
in the offshore tax rate to 21 from 10
and a half okay all that stuff we've
already talked about let's let's
emphasize one area here
so janet yellen goes to the g20 saying
hey why don't we all have the same
corporate tax rate
rather than just u.s raising it why
don't we all agree on the same number
what do you think about that
well if you're and i have a list of the
countries with the lowest
corporate tax rate it makes no sense for
you to do because that's your
competitive advantage what are the
countries we're talking about
hungary nine percent montenegro nine
percent bosnia and herzegovina uh
ten percent bulgaria ten percent this is
corporate tax right now you're talking
lowest corporate taxes in the world uh
moldova 12
cyprus 12 and a half percent everyone's
familiar with that ireland has very low
corporate tax rate 12 and a half apples
albania 15
so you're talking about basically
somewhere about 10 and 15
for most of these countries this is
their competitive advantage
like why the hell are you going to
moldova or uh
montenegro unless they have to relocate
your corporate business
unless they actually have low corporate
tax rates so we kind of covered this
with byron last week
and it's stuff that blew my mind i
didn't understand the double taxation
with
you know if your corporate tax and then
if you want to pull money out there's an
income tax and
yeah and all that but i think where
yellen is going with this and a couple
different points here is
i think what she's aiming to do i'm not
saying that these countries are going to
play ball because i think that it
mitigates their
um competitive advantage why would they
give that up but she's basically selling
this will prevent offshoring it was
essentially what that whole repatriation
incentivizing
um thing that was truck that the trump
tax cuts were addressing
so i don't know if these countries are
going to play ball and i think this is
something she's
putting out think about it what do you
think about it what do you think about
getting the corporate tax rate for g
you know the top 20 whatever economies
you want to talk about to be
the same exact number what do you think
about that is that a good thing or is
that a bad thing
i think if you're america and you have
traditionally the highest tax rate 35
percent and trump that it
brought it down to 21 and now it's at 28
or biden's at least
pitching 28. i know they're in a round
of negotiations right now maybe they
meet in the middle of their 25.
i think it's freaking great for america
but i don't know who i'm sorry who is
america
who is america who is america you said
it's great for america who is america
american corporations you're talking
about taxpayers are talking about no no
but you said it's great for america
who is america you said you said if
america is able to get this corporate
tax rate to
go and be the same it is great for
america
to keep our corporations why would we
want our corporations
so who wins though who wins in america
who wins in america if we keep all that
the same and there is no competition
for corporate tax rate which part of
america wins
the people the entrepreneur small
business owners
or the tax collectors in dc the u.s
government
the u.s treasury wait a minute wait a
minute you said all of the above wins
i think so tell me tell me how all the
above wins well if the corporations stay
here
uh and they're paying lower taxes than
having to go elsewhere there's some
incentives at that
more jobs but obviously the big one is
taxes the irs you know
i think that's something that they'd be
interested in so so then let me ask you
a question
who keeps the government honest if the
government doesn't have any competition
who keeps the government honest
corporations i guess how do you do that
you don't have the final say yeah the
corporations are
nothing they're nobodies how do you how
do you keep
a government honest if if the
corporation has no
other place to go like no other place to
go
where what what i mean where is the
leverage for the customer
and the corporation to complain and say
we don't like the way we're being
treated
what's the government going to say go to
any of the g20 it's the same thing
yeah you don't like us you know go to
turkey
figure it out because it's same
everywhere
you lose officially
and you have no say you already if you
go to dmv and you file a complaint about
the envy on yelp
you know how many people read it nobody
yeah go post the review on yelp and see
how many the
dmv employees respond to you go ahead
try today yeah
go to your local dmv go to the front
desk clinton and catherine
or johnny he's not going to say hi how
are you how was your day well have a
wonderful day
he's just going to tell you excuse me
sit down and go right on yelp
catherine told me to sit down and i
didn't like it and see how many people
are going to say
we're sorry you feel that way we totally
understand that's not the right approach
we are working to bring it up in our
next training routine to make sure that
never happens again
go ahead and see where tsa or yelp tsa
or dmv go file a complaint about tsa on
yelp
go ahead i'd love to see you do it let's
see what happens where's accountability
if all of a sudden right
yelling convinces all of these guys tom
let me just turn it over to you here
big countries have been doing this to
little countries for a thousand years
and the big countries are trying to take
the competitive advantage away from the
small countries
the reason apple's in ireland and a
million other examples you could have
is because there is an economic
advantage and there is a labor force
there
and it was better for them and better
for their stock price and better for
their overall return
and now you've got the empire strikes
back
where they're coming in and saying wait
a minute why don't we just make the
high tax rate even for everyone
she's not talking about the 15 tax rate
in ireland she's talking about the 35
percent rate
why don't we just make 35 percent
everything now the small companies
small countries oh wow they're going to
collect 35 tax yeah but they're going to
have fewer
you know organizations coming to them to
do it so
big country has been doing it to small
countries forever i mean this goes back
to revolutionary times
where britain would harvest trees
from the u.s take them build furniture
and then sell them back to the colonists
that's called mercantilism
and people say wait a minute so you cut
down the tree that was in america
you then turned it into a chair and then
sold it back to the american that lived
down the street from the tree cut down
yeah that's right so
big countries have been doing this to
small countries forever the fact that
yellen brings up her proposal
is only to benefit the dirt that she's
standing on when she makes that proposal
which represents
this is the u.s government the u.s
treasury that's it
president obama proposal announced last
week watch this that's my opinion
this is what she says by the way
president biden's proposal announced
last week call
for bold domestic action including the
race to raise the u.s minimum tax rate
and
renewed international engagement
recognizing that it is important to work
with other countries to end the
pressures of tax comp
competition and corporate tax let me
read the sentence to work with other
countries to end the pressure of tax
competition
hey ireland knock it off yeah let me
read this statement one more time
bold president biden's proposal
announced last week called for bold
domestic action including to raise
the u.s minimum tax rate and renewed
international
engagement recognizing that it is
important to work with other countries
to end the pressures
of tax competition
yeah and corporate tax-based erosion
pressures on who on her said miss yellen
we are working with g20 nations to agree
to a global
minimum corporate tax rate that can stop
the race to the bottom look
let me let me give you let me read those
last three lines stop the race to wear
the bottle which is benefits who the
government
no the race to the bottom benefits the
uh the smaller
the company that can go where it wants
but let me say this to you let me say
this to you
you ever hear when uh sanders gets up
there and sanders will say
an argument like this or sanders would
say obama would say it or hillary would
say any of these guys would say
how can we be the most powerful richest
country in the world and we don't offer
health care
every other country in europe does it
right you know what happens here
they can't use that argument because
when when a politician says that the
average voter says what
the average voter says huh if all these
other countries in europe and canada
offer health care
why don't we you know what i'll vote for
it
it
is an american right to have health
insurance given to everybody
because europe's doing it fair no
problem i get something i want something
you just told me i could get something
so now i want it but
flip it now on this side they can't say
we're raising a corporate taxer to 28
because that's what all the european
countries do
see they don't have that statement today
to make
so they want to get it up so they can
say look it's what everybody does
it's normal it's what everybody does
that's right they don't have that
argument because the moment they say
they want to raise a corporate tax or
guess what republicans say
we are the highest we have the highest
corporate tax rate where
in the world and democrats are like and
then the voter the average voter
the average voter voter is not a dummy
voter sits there and says
we have the highest corporate tax rate
in the world why would america have the
highest corporate tax rate in the world
let me go do a little bit of research
they come back and say yeah i'm not with
that i don't think we should have the
highest court even a democrat
would say i don't want to have the
highest corporate tax rate in the world
but if they get this argument
in then guess what it's okay if we have
the highest corporate tax rate in the
world
you want to eliminate competition with
government taxes
are you kidding me that's what saves
america where we have
like the other day i was talking to um
uh uh i can't wait for this interview i
lit i seriously cannot wait for this
interview to come out with uh the guy
who bought uh
people's nft medical bid right 69
million dollars
and he said i said so why do you live in
singapore
he says why do i live in singapore he
says no taxes on capital gains
my income taxes are around 10 or 20
percent no regulation
i don't have to report anything nobody
wants to know how much money i have
he says do you know why i don't want to
move to america i said why look what the
guy
says he says i don't want to move to
america because i'm worried the moment i
go into america
for the rest of my life they can trace
me to pay taxes on things i did in the
past
because now they have my fingerprint i
don't want that singapore doesn't care
who i am and what i'm doing
singapore all they care about is for me
to pay 10 to 20 percent of income
zero capital gains low regulation
nothing
this is why myself and many others like
living
in singapore you think america likes
that hell no
do you think these politicians today in
the left like yelens and warren and
aoc's and biden those guys like that
absolutely not but you know what a
message like that from singapore does
pisses these people off to say damn it i
was about to take you to 35
but you know what why don't we just
settle at 25 corporate tax rate
if we don't have that argument from the
other side they can take you to 35. you
can't say nothing because all they're
going to do is say
hey g20 we're going to take this to 35
you guys also got to take it to 35.
and they have to do it it's a monopoly
so it's controlled
the word that i'm coming to mind because
you brought it up there is just
competition without competition you have
nothing do we have competition of course
right now this podcast does it have
competition yes we do do you have
competition with a live setting
yeah of course do i have competition
does everybody here have in a job have
competition yeah does tom have
competition
does the uber driver have competition
does lift have competition
does a pizza joint have competition
doesn't it italy
you know a sub joint have competition do
states have competition
so should government why only put the
competition on us
small businesses and employees and
states and take the competition off the
government
how is that fair so we get to have the
pressure of going to sleep at night
worrying about our competitor
taking a market share from us but you
don't get to have that pressure no we
believe in equal opportunity
and you politicians also need to have
competition well i think what it
what uh you know as an american you want
to say like
well no you know we you know america
first and we no one should compete with
america no
it holds america accountable so we can't
get fat and lazy if you have no
competition you're the only person
you're the fat cat
you're only company doing x y or z and
you have no competition that's how
you'll become fat lazy sloppy
like your dmv example if someone goes on
to
yelp and says well uh mary down to the
dmv told me to sit down
and there's no response there's no
accountability how do you improve
so like you always say
outlast out improve and strategize and
if
you don't have to do any of that because
you have no competition
that's how empires crumble absolutely
right and you know there's a little case
study on this it's really easy
eduardo savren who is the co-founder of
facebook
who moved to singapore and then
renounced his u.s citizenship by the way
he was living in singapore since like
2007.
he renounces his citizenship 2009 and
people said
wait a minute you just did this to avoid
seven hundred thousand dollars
seven hundred um seven hundred million
dollars south of thailand
and um in capital gains tech he said no
no no my wife and i just love singapore
right and he now lives in singapore and
so
that's the whole point it's obviously in
southeast asia why do all that
pull it up on the map why do the oil
barons and the oil pirates live in
belize
same reason and people say oh these are
tax havens these
no they're not this is these are choices
these are valid choices
you're saying that they're not tax
havens no no if they're not if all taxes
were equal you wouldn't be living in
singapore
no way absolutely not if all taxes were
no you wouldn't but by the way
singapore is necessary go to images go
to images real quick where
by the way take the map outs everybody
kind of knows where it's at take the map
out go to the building with the pool
going out keep going out keep going up
keep going out
okay so go down a little bit pull it
down a little bit you got thailand you
got vietnam you got cambodia malaysia
south
south right there to the east of uh to
the west of uh
uh uh indonesia indonesia you have
australia on this side but you kind of
see what's outside
east asia the islands now go to the
images of singapore go to images of
singapore
go to images of singapore uh singapore
they go
and just click on images okay i got to
tell you kyle sam's coming for your job
bro
they're they're opposition there's a
swimming pool that goes all the way
around that hotel it's a beautiful hotel
uh uh are beautiful
the wild you've been to singapore twice
by the way we can't hear your audio so
say hey can you hear me now yeah go
ahead okay
the shows that they have at night
beautiful
trees is it like vegas is it somewhat
like vegas
vegas and macau combined yes yeah
so so by the way a lot of movies are
shot here just so you know a lot of
movies are shot in singapore it's a
beautiful place
and this is not a pitch for singapore
this is for pitch that singapore is very
necessary for america
singapore is so imagine there is no
argument for us right now to talk about
what singapore does
the guy says capital gained zero why pay
taxes on cash he was confused he says i
don't understand why america taxes you
guys on capital gains
i don't get it why would you pay tax on
capital gains why are americans paying
tax on capital gains
right and biden goes back again this
week talking about a well tax
back at it again so this whole concept
about global corporate tax folks if
you're listening to this look
left right middle wherever you are if
you're listening to this do
a little bit of research on what global
corporate tax could do to you
especially if you're living in america
if you're living in any other country
outside of america don't even think
about voting for that to be passed if
anybody in your state
or country is pitching you on you know
the powerful people
of us are pitching us to have the same
corporate tax rate you may want to think
twice before agreeing
to want to vote for that go ahead
absolutely and here's something else
to go look at and everyone is listening
go get smart
go look what the federal trade
commission was saying when
sprint and t-mobile were trying to merge
oh this will reduce competition
competition brings more features more
functionality
more differentiation and better pricing
for the consumer remember that pat
we if there's only two or three wireless
carriers they may all just freeze
pricing together
like only two gas stations on corner
they face each other and they never move
the price of gas down per gallon you
know what i mean
so federal trade commission is very big
on this we protect the consumer
we want to make sure there's competition
in the marketplace which brings lower
pricing
new products differentiation those
people that are at the federal trade
commission are specifically not allowed
apparently to be at the state department
because if they're at the state
department they'd be like what are your
knuckleheads saying the competition
among countries is good no no
go back to the federal trade commission
you're not allowed in here turn that
guy's badge off don't let him get
through this door anymore
it's a hypocrisy that's inside of our
own government on one side we're arguing
that we need to level the playing field
for us and on the other side we're at
the federal trade commission
not letting companies merge together
because oh wait a minute that would be
monopolistic that wouldn't
come on my gosh isn't it a hypocrisy
yeah i mean listen one of
the best things in the world is the
pressure of having competition
the pressure of having competition is
what makes wives treat their husbands
better
husbands treat their wives better
parents to be better parents
men to be better men women to be better
women teachers to be better teachers
customers to be better customers
employees to be better employees
movies to be better movies sports teams
to be better sports teams
competition like the other yesterday
we're sitting at soho house
what did adrian put up on his phone
what did agent put on his phone what
were we watching oh you're watching the
game gonzaga
how many times do we look at the screen
five times yeah in a span of 45 minutes
you know why because the game was why
the hell am i going to watch a 19 point
lead by baylor
yeah what am i going to watch and you
know the baylor the the
gonzaga guy said i don't know if you saw
this thing going viral gonzaga guy said
we have the best offensive team in all
of college basketball
the baylor team said we lift weights
with baylor's football team
and that's exactly what happened it was
a shellacking on what happened with the
they lost pretty pretty bad on what you
played
but here's the point we didn't watch the
phone about five times no
i literally looked 15 point lead i
looked
11 minutes 17 point lead i looked two
minutes
19 point there's no competition
you will not pay attention to it one of
the best things for our health and our
sanity
is competition absolutely competition
you would not be in shape today if it
wasn't for competition so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you